there were three big things that are
happening now that never happened in my
lifetime before never happened in our
lifetimes before okay
um those three things are an enormous
amount of uh debt production that
creation and the monetization of that
debt
um second
um
large internal conflicts of populism on
the left and populism of the riot
brought about by the largest wealth
death and wealth gaps and values gaps
that we've had since 1900 this is all
measurable
and then third
um greatest amount of external conflict
due to the first time in our lifetimes a
rising power or Rising Powers become
incomparable to the United States and or
the war of great world power to produce
the conflicts that we're in now when I
look at that my instinct is then to say
okay I need to see the patterns so what
I did is then I went back and I studied
I saw the last 500 years of History I'm
not an academic trying to write
academically but I needed to understand
those patterns in the close effect
relationships to deal with what's
happening now so the answer to your
question I think
is to understand the cause effect
relationships because the causes happen
before the effects and if you understand
the causes and the effects that they're
going to have you're going to be able to
be in a better position than if you
don't